hello everyone and I know what you're
gonna say why are you showing us an
image MIDI no game today when yesterday
was his birthday
well friends of ours invited us to come
celebrate the birth of their son so we
stayed we stayed there pretty late and
of course I didn't have time to do a
video yesterday because of that but it
was fun and the boys name is neo like
you know from the matrix very cool but
that being said let's get back to this
game at the game was played in 1951 in
Baku Azerbaijan and Russia Deshmukh Dino
has the black pieces against under
Lilian tau and this is a clash of two
legends before I show you the game I
just want to say a little bit about
Lilienthal because I really want you to
understand how strong stronger
grandmaster he was he he was born in
Moscow although already at the age of
two he moved to Hungary Hungary so he
became a Hungarian chess grandmaster and
throughout his career he defeated he
defeated last year he defeated kappa
blanka he defeated
alian he defeated max over he defeated
Mikhail Botvinnik he defeated Sunnyslope
he defeated Vera manchak the Women's
World Champion
so he had a very successful chess career
and people really really liked him he
was a you know very likable guy one time
when he was younger
Alexander alien actually paid for his
tournament fee because he didn't have
any money just so he could play and he's
actually one of the few people that have
a that have an equal score against Jose
raúl capablanca there's even a story
when Bobby Fischer was playing against
Bobby Spassky Boris Spassky in their
1992 world champion Chess Championship
rematch that Bobby Fischer actually
spotted under Lilienthal in the crowd
and he greeted him with he captures on
f6 that's one famous move from
lilienthal's game where he crushed kappa
blanka with a beautiful Queen sacrifice
so you know everyone everyone knew who
Lilienthal was and everyone liked the
guy but like I said in this game he
faces a receding edge Medina
so let's see this game lilienthal plays
the four and we have Knight to f6 c4 d6
we have the old Indian defense g5 and
now sorry Knight to f3 and now me v the
so-called Ukrainian a variation of the
of the old Indian defense and we have
nice - f3
capturing this and depriving black of
castling doesn't really achieve anything
for white so it's a pretty equivalent
game and white just simplified the
position
this is not something lilienthal is
interested in doing so after E 5 Knight
to f3 Knight bt7
and the g3 now we have B captures on d4
Knight captures on d4 and g6 preparing
Bishop g7 and castles Bishop g2 Bishop
g7 castles castles and we have b3 and
Rashida immediately jumps in Knight to
c5 and I'm I'm I mean I'm astonished how
good
Najma Dino's position with the black
pieces is he has this beautiful bishop
on g7 he has this beautiful bishop on c8
already you know it can choose wherever
it wants to go this is this is something
you want to always struggle doing with
the black pieces but engagement in of
accomplishes it's pretty pretty easily
and like I said this is move 9 and you
know already has this beautiful night on
c5 and here moves like efore would be
welcome Queen c2 is an idea but
Lilienthal doesn't like knish Medina was
knight on c5 and he kicks it away before
Knights to e6 now and now Knight to b3
not allowing the exchange to happen nice
capture screen captures and then the
bishop is lined up with the Queen and
with the rook
so Knight back to b3 Knight to d7 now
Bishop to b2 and here we have Knight to
e5 Rasheed is going going for pieces
activity Knight to a5 now Lilienthal is
attacking the b7 pawn and well there are
a couple of ideas to consider here you
could simply defend it with rook to b8
but this is not how but a sheet plays
chess
she plays Knight to d4 he ignores the b7
pawn and
he goes for activity improving the
position of his knights now of course
you can't capture Queen captures losses
immediately tonight of three check and
you've opened up the attack from the
bishop to the Queen and before so we
lose the Queen and the game but this
night the d4 isn't isn't the greatest
move
for example if lilienthal played Knight
to d5 now he would open up a discovered
attack to the knight from the Queen and
the bishop and Rashid would simply have
to retreat with the knight eaters the c6
or ecigs but this is this is obviously
the nature Medina effect after 94 Knight
to a4 was played and I don't I mean I
don't care how many world champions you
defeated but you have an item a4 and a5
this is I don't know this is not how how
I will start to play chess
c5 by image Medina and it's it's it's a
very complicated position already I move
14 White has so much so much to choose
from you have to calculate B capture c5
you have to calculate Bishop captures on
d4 you have to calculate do you capture
with the knight on b7 to capture with
the bishop on b7 so a lot of things to
consider here and in this position a
lilienthal went a3 and this is this is
far from the best move what he should
have played was Knight captures on b7
and after Bishop captures Bishop
captures now Knight captures on c4
Bishop captures on a8 and knife capture
some b2 Knight captures and queen now
captures an a8 and Rasheed would give up
the exchange but he would have
conversation with the Queen on this
beautiful diagonal and the dark square
Bishop the knight is also very nicely
placed and instead if you don't want to
capture the rook maybe a better move
would be Bishop captures on d4 but again
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
again Queen captures Rashida would never
capture that rook he prefers the dark
square Bishop and the Queen but then it
has something like Queen c1 and night
the e3 check not to check but attacking
the Queen the rook and also threatening
checkmate on g2 so Knight would have to
be captured the bishop
Bishop captures would check the Queen
the King can move anywhere recast the
block and now see capture some before
and it's an extremely complicated
position probably something that would
end up if Lillian captured the knight on
b7 machine is down a whole rook but I
mean the the wit would extremely correct
play white can hold this but against
Rashida who knows it's hard to say
so after c5 little lilienthal decided
not to go for the b7 pawn and he played
a three but now immediately
Rashid jumps in Bishop to g4 now
threatening d2 pawn we have Bishop
captures on d4 see captures on d4 and h3
kicking the Bishop Bishop to e6 and now
c5 again if you play something like
Knight captures here then you get Queen
to d7 attacking the knight in the h3
pawn so so I mean it it is the best
variation for white but it's very very
complicated to define the right moves
for example here we have to play c5 now
Bishop captures on h3 is good because of
c6 so after something like d5 now you
have to play Knight to d6 and after
Knight to c4 Knight captures D captures
on c4 it's a you know it's a pretty
equal game but Rasheed would have two
beautiful pawns on c4 and d4 although
although there is compensation
I don't think white would ever capture
the rock on a8 I mean that Bishop will
be a critical defensive piece if this
position ever did happen but it didn't
after Bishop to e6 c5 was played now b5
by Rasheed and again you have a lot a
lot of things to consider here for
example if you if you move the knight
Knight goes back to be to simply D
captures on c5 you know you have a
massive pawn center white can't
recapture because the knight on a5 is
hanging so after b5 Lilienthal played
see captures on b6 we have a capture
some b6 now opening up a discovered
attack from the rook
tonight's Bishop captures on a8 now the
bishop has to be I mean it's a Rashid is
the one winning the exchange but you
know you can feel from the position that
it's actually a Rashid who's winning
this exchange Queen captures an a8 and
now Knights to b6 attacking the Queen
and Queen to a6 now with an attack on
the night and here so night back to a4
and now we have Bishop captures on h3
finally and Lilienthal isn't crazy to
play a move like rook rook to e1 you
know you you can't be too materialistic
if you play something like rook do you
want to save the rook then d3 is coming
opening up this beautiful diagonal for
the Bishop rook to c1 and now Bishop to
g4 piling up on D to pawn and after rook
to c3 Bishop captures I need to rook
captures D captures on e2 Queen to e1
Queen to b5 now and this comes with with
a whole lot of threats
Knight to be to because the knight was
attacked and now Knight to g4 and this
is terrible
you opened up the discovered attack from
the bishop on the rook on the night but
this isn't even the greatest threat the
girl the greatest threat is Queen to h5
followed by Queen to H to checkmate and
the white can't stop both threats so
after Bishop to h3 Lilienthal doesn't
really care about that rook he I mean he
would wish that and his Medina would
capture it with his Bishop so rook the
c1 going for development d3 now he
character son d3 and now Queen to AAA
now Rasheed is threatening checkmate on
G to f3 blocking checkmate and now
Knight to g4 again knight can be
captured because of checkmate on g2 so
nice to see 4 and we have Bishop to d4
check King has to go to h1 and now as
you can see all of the squares around
the King are covered this is this is a
very serious meeting net being created
here Queen to d5 now again parish it
goes for some ideas of Queen to h5 and
the game is over
the position is so good that white
simply can't do anything here rook to c2
was played now rush it rush it could
play Queen h5 I mean it it's a winning
move after half captures and g4 and
Bishop captures you check the King you
attack the Queen and after rook to h2
attacking blacks Queen now simply Queen
b5 again checking the White King and
also you lose the Queen and the game but
after rook to c2 or a she'd simply play
Bishop captures on f1 and in this
position the legendary Grandmaster under
lilienthal resigned the game white
doesn't have a move Queen to h5 is the
threat of course if you capture the
Bishop Queen captures then again Queen
age 5 and there is no defense can g2
Queen h2 is checkmate or you have to
give up the Queen but that's pretty
pointless you know again you end up
being checkmated but after up c2 Rashid
simply Bishop captures on f1 a slow move
for the end of the game and this
masterpiece was created under Lilienthal
died in 2010 and at the age of 99 and
before he died he was the oldest living
Grandmaster you know in the world so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it it's a truly a clash of
legends I would like to thank selling
via wDAF
Brian crane and Isaac Hinman for a
contribution to my channel I think a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon and I will put a link in
the description below where you can
check out some of my previous games on
Rashid regiment Dean of thank you all
for watching and I'll see you soon